hey guys today I'm bringing you a video
about Hubble Jon Snow find out who his
true parents really are and what his
birth name is something that John will
certainly find out throughout the
upcoming seasons which is not
questionable but still the question
remains how will he find out the truth
showrunners decided to reveal to our
John's true identity in the season 6
finale John is not Ned's bastard
but rather son of Lyanna stark and
rhaegar targaryen but it's yet to be
seen Hubbell Jon find out the truth
while on the other hand just as Jon Snow
we don't know John's birth name it's yet
to be seen how the showrunners reveal
John's birth name to John and to us
whether it's Viserys Joe Harris Aegon
Amon or something entirely else a few
days ago I made a video about what
John's birth name might be in which I
brought you a theory about John's birth
name being the series but today's video
is not about what John's birth name it
be but is about travel Jon Snow find out
the truth the truth that Ned kept
throughout his whole life as he promised
he would to his dying sister Lyanna the
truth which only Ned and his best friend
Howland Reed know about well bran found
out about it in his visions two months
ago I delivered your video about Howland
Reed in which I brought you the
possibility of his appearance in the
upcoming seasons along with the
possibility of him being of a huge
importance in John's life as I believe
that he will be the one to reveal John's
real identity to John a video which I
highly recommend you to check it out
however in my opinion we will find out
John's birth name in the upcoming season
while Jon will find out the truth about
both his parentage and his birth name in
the last final 8 season before I go any
further let me just highlight that in my
opinion we'll find out John's birth name
by completely different sources than
John Woo himself through different
people and through different episodes
just like John's true parentage which we
learned about in the previous season in
brains vision while showrunners revealed
to us Jon Snow's true identity with bran
entering vision by communing with the
Weaver tree in the haunted forest
whereupon he followed his father into
the Tower of joy and witness the reunion
between his father Ned and his dying
aunt Lyanna an emotional scene which had
also revealed John's true identity
obviously Jack himself won't find it out
through branch vision as faded in my
opinion in the upcoming season
the serious will reveal John's birth
name but only to us since I believe in
lis plot which says that Sam with brands
help we'll figure out John's parentage
we'll find out some kind of prove that
he's a legitimized sign of Lena stark
and rhaegar targaryen along with his
birth name which will apparently happen
in the final episode of the upcoming
season if you're wondering why wouldn't
bran revealed the truth to Jon about his
parents on their first meeting it's
pretty simple so let's just put it this
way even if bran wooden firstly tried to
find out the proof from either the books
or even from Holland reading in the
first place since Bryan knows that
Holland was there beside Ned and knows
pretty much every single detail that
happened in the Tower of joy even if he
would decide to reveal the truth to John
without any hard proofs in that case
bran still won't be able to do so as
John will not be at Winterfell at the
time of brand's rival John will already
be a dragon stone as leaked photos
confirmed if you are wondering what kind
of proofs are going favored to a theory
that will find out the truth in a scene
in which bran and Sam will find out the
actual proof from the books while Jon
will find it out in the last final
season let's just put it this way not
only that this would fit perfectly with
the series but there are also few Lee
photos of similarly Gillian little Sam
in which we can clearly see them leaving
Old Town which will take place in either
episode 4 or episode 5 as director Matt
Jackman was spotted on the same filming
set while it's pretty easy to assume
that they will be heading to Winterfell
to sum up we already know John's true
parentage while we will most likely
found out his birth name in the season 7
finale in a scene between brain and Sam
but Jon Snow knows nothing the question
remains
huddle John find out his true parentage
and his birth name an important question
which in my opinion beside bran stark
and similarly who will share sin which
will reveal to us fans for John's birth
name is also involves Howland Reed who
will in my opinion be the one to reveal
to Jon Snow his true parentage and his
birth name for all of you that didn't
watch a video that I published a few
months ago a video in which I was
talking about the importance of Howland
in the upcoming seasons and for all of
you that are wondering why Holland read
the chosen one to reveal the truth to
Jon let me just say a few sentences
about Howland
Howland Reed is the man whose children
Meera and Jojen played an important role
in brain Stark's life the man that was
the first who charged against the sword
of the morning whereupon he was slashed
across the chest by Dane and almost died
but also a man who saved Ned from a
certain death save Ned Stark who gave
his best but couldn't stand a chance
against ser Arthur Dayne superior
fighting skills and got himself disarmed
the same man the Lord of greywater watch
loyal vessel of House Stark Howland Reed
has played very important role in Starks
life but saving that from a certain
death is playing a very important role
because if not for his children Bram
probably would not even have become a
three-eyed Raven additionally he would
have probably been dead and will
doubtlessly play a huge role in the
upcoming seasons considering that he's
the only living person beside bran that
knows the truth about Joshua identity
beside Ned Lord Reed was the only man
that survived fight against one of the
best swordsmen that the Seven Kingdoms
has ever had
meaning that he knows a secret a secret
which only two people in the entire
world know bran only knows about his
parentage due to his ability of having a
visions of the past but Howland Reed was
actually there
Howland witness John's birth and that is
why I don't see Howland Reed not
appearing in the final season this same
man whose friendship and loyalty are
highly admire Baal Howland Reed is
unquestionably willing to take the
secret to his grave the secret which I
believe how it will reveal to Jon Snow
same secret of which we've already been
introduced with most of it with John's
true parentage while the John's birth
name will be introduced in the final
episode of the upcoming season in
conclusion we can expect to find out
John's birth name in the seventh season
true bran stark and similarly while Jon
Snow will find out the truth in the last
finally its season by Howland Reed in my
opinion I recommend you to check out a
video mind about Howland Reed and the
role that he might play in revealing the
truth to Jon Snow a video in which have
also explained you the importance of the
neck the region of Westeros ruled over
by House Reed and as always let me know
your opinion about all of this in the
comment section down below I hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see you in the
next one peace
[Music]